Emily Blunt may not be meant for
superhero movies she wasn't just
approached once but twice by Marvel and
turned them down both times the first
was when she was asked to play Black
Widow in Iron Man 2 but she stressed
that she had to turn them down because
she was contractually obligated to star
in Gulliver's Travels even though she'd
say I didn't want to do Gulliver's
Travels I wanted to work with Robert
Downey Jr it would have been amazing
ouch luckily Marvel gave Emily a second
chance a few years later when they
approached her to play Agent Carter but
again it didn't work out schedule wise
as it turns out Emily's not too upset
about it I don't know if superheroes are
for me and why is that it's been
exhausted